[Music]  [Music]  I have to sing I had to play the music  it's it's not just in me it is me when  life gets me down I play my guitar the  rest of the world may follow the rules  but I must follow my heart you know that  feeling like there's a song in the air  and it's playing just for you oh so  close you reach out and touch it I never  knew I could want something so much but  it's true  [Music]  never underestimate the power of music  no one was going to hand me my future it  was up to me to reach for my dream grab  it tight and make it come true  [Applause]  all right moving the side  what's going on just dreaming  you got to stay with me boys know where  we are  [Music]  this isn't a Jew then you're all really  I'll do  [Music]  you